in just four days the New England
Patriots will face off against the Los
Angeles Rams in Super Bowl 53 the last
time the teams met in a Super Bowl was
17 years ago in 2002 that year the
Patriots beat the Rams and quarterback
Tom Brady earned his first MVP award
under the ownership of Robert Kraft the
Patriots have won 18 division titles 10
conference titles and 5 Super Bowl
championships that's more than any other
team over the last 25 years
crap joins us from Atlanta as his team
prepares for Sunday's big game good
morning mr. Kraft thank you so much for
joining us good morning Nora it's great
to be with you congratulations on your
25th season of ownership I know this
will be your 10th Super Bowl appearance
what's on the mind of the Patriots team
today well you know it's such a thrill
to be here and just thinking how things
can change so fast you know like you
said 17 years ago to the day on Sunday
we were the biggest underdogs in the
history of Super Bowl 14 points and we
came alive at a time that the country
was hurting you know right after 9/11
and it was just a thrilling moment to
win our first Super Bowl and and start
this run that's been fantastic for our
fans you know what's so interesting as
you look at the dynasty that you have
created because New England is now the
first team in NFL history to win five
Super Bowls with the same owner you the
same head coach Bill Belichick and the
same quarterback how does that
continuity lead to success how have you
kept that team together well you know in
life if you want to develop something
that has sustainability the first thing
is you try to attract good people that
fit your culture the trick of that is to
make sure there's never division from
within there can be a lot of different
opinions from within but that you keep
it together and get everyone to check
their ego
the front door one of my rules is I
never make a change unless I know I'm
making an improvement and we've been
privileged to have you know the to keep
people who are the greatest in my
opinion in the history of the ninety
nine year history of the NFL at their
positions and keeping them together
it'll be two decades next year and
that's that's the main task of ownership
it is its historic and it's
unprecedented and I know Tom has said in
an interview that there's zero chance
that this is his last NFL season and so
his coach Belichick definitely coming
back to we we have a great pact he loves
what he does he's so good at it we've
created an environment where he can work
to the best of his abilities so I'm
quite confident he'll be back when you
think about their team and they walk out
on that field on Sunday or run out on
the field on Sunday what's the message
that you want to have in their mind you
you might never be there again it took
us over 30 years to get to our first
game so we we try to make sure that
people are completely focused on nothing
else but the game and doing what they
can to close the order we we've had a
pretty good record the last few years
and on Sunday we had a little throwing a
going-away party for our fans and 35,000
people came out on a Sunday really just
for seeing the players and coaches for
20 minutes so fans have been a big part
of our success and the support they've
given us well we are looking forward to
the game on Sunday congratulations on 25
years of ownership we but wish both the
Patriots and the Rams a good safe fun
game we will all be watching mr. Kraft
thank you so much thanks and just know
that the last thing coach is going to
tell the team we need CBS to get good
ratings
you do what you got to do to make that
out the Patriots and the Rams and all
those great players there's no doubt it
will be huge ratings thank you so much
and you guys snore thank you and you can
catch Super Bowl 53 and all the pregame
festivities right here on CBS starting
at 6:00 p.m. Eastern this Sunday when
that game will get a lot of eyeballs you
know it's more than just a business it
is a family affair son Jonathan as
president of the organization as well a
lot of passion there